et direction maintenant la russie le
parti au pouvoir russie unie est arrivé
en tête des élections législatives
devant les communistes avec plus de 46%
des voix c'est un peu moins qu'en 2016
vladimir poutine a remercié tout à
l'heure les russes pour leur confiance
le scrutin aura duré trois jours de
vendredi à dimanche 108 millions
d'électeurs russe appelés aux urnes pour
renouveler les 450 députés de la douma
la chambre basse du parlement les
résultats définitifs sont attendus ces
toutes prochaines heures la
correspondance à moscou deux vérins
goffman
la porte parole du kremlin dmitri peskov
a constaté que le score du parti
communiste était en progression il a
également noté que les bons résultats de
nouveau parti dont un nouvelle personne
fait zeller pour les premières fois ces
candidats à la douma écoutez
effectivement on le parti communiste a
amélioré ses résultats il y à de
nouveaux partis qui ont également montré
des résultats très positifs
les élections sont organisées pour que
les électeurs expriment leur préférence
mais nous voyons que la principale
préférence des électeurs et russie unie
c'est le parti au pouvoir
pour le président sans doute le
caractère compétitif transparent
équitable des élections qui ont eu lieu
a toujours été et reste la chose la plus
importante à cet égard nous évaluons
comme positif le processus électoral qui
s'est déroulé et en ce qui concerne le
reste eh bien je crois que c'est ça la
chose essentielle pour le chef de l'état
selon la chef de la commission centrale
électorale europe en fils huit cas de
bourrage d'urnes ont été enregistrés les
bulletins concernés ont été annulés et
des enquêtes ont été lancées quant à ces
violations et la pension va demander aux
commissions électorales locales da les
résultats des élections dans les
circonscriptions où des violations ont
été enregistrés en tout la commission
centrale électorale a recensé plus de
vingt cinq mille bulletins annulés
écoutez dans l'état actuel des choses
huit cas de bourrage d'urnes ont été
confirmés dans six points de la
fédération de russie
en république d'haïti gay et dans les
région de briansk d'ivanovo de kemerovo
de moscou et de saratov dans tous ces
cas les bulletins de vote ont été
invalidés et des enquêtes sont en cours
dans la république d'asie gueller région
de briansk et de kemerovo les présidents
des commissions électorales
divisionnaire où les bourrages sont
survenus ont d'ores et déjà été démis de
leurs fonctions
jérôme lambert député à l'assemblée
nationale invité à observer la tenue des
législatives russes a affirmé que le
tout ce qu'il a pu voir a été
transparent et ne contredisait en rien à
la législation écoutez toutes les
opérations auxquelles nous avons pu
assister sont parfaitement transparente
au droit électorat qui est en vigueur
dans tous les pays occidentaux
les électeurs ont le choix entre
plusieurs candidats viennent librement
dans leur bureau de vote exprimé leur
choix en passant par l'isoloir
et en votant semble-t-il tout à fait
librement le scrutin des législatives
russes a débuté le 17 septembre et s'est
étalé sur trois jours afin de limiter
les risques épidémiques liés aux colis
19 ces élections interviennent un peu
plus d'un an après l'adoption 2020 des
amendements constitutionnels qui ont
considérablement élargi le pouvoir des
législateurs us